[Music]
so why should women want an end
symbolism well I do think it's a bold
statement that women want an Interphone
ism but I think it's sort of backed up
by polls are sometimes untrustworthy but
there's been some interesting ones you
go poll and in the last few years
suggested that there was only about 30%
of men and women who identified with the
label of feminists and a Fawcett Society
poll back in I think it was 2016 put
that figure at about 7 or 8% so if you
if you go up to one on the street and
you say what is your burning issue what
is the thing that you politically
identify with it's very unlikely that
you're going to say feminists and I
think that's because feminism has not
become something that isn't political
it's become an identity that you kind of
wear as a badge it's a bit vacuous it
doesn't actually have any sense of
women's freedom and liberation anymore
and and so I think it's time to dispense
with it and to come up with a better way
of arguing for the kind of freedoms that
women are still withheld from and argue
for a better means of women's liberation
do you think you could argue that people
don't want to identify as feminists
because of a dehumanization of the
feminists in media I hate this argument
which is when people say but you really
are a feminist don't you get it because
you know the dictionary definition says
that feminism is about equality of the
sexes and that's actually what the
Fawcett Society did when its press
release when it ran its headline about
that very low number of people who are
feminists it said we are a nation of
hidden feminists and what that
essentially is saying is no no you
stupid person
you don't know what you mean I know what
what you mean and I'm actually going to
correct you with the right terminology
and path that's that's kind of a key
reason why I really feel quite strongly
about the problems with feminism because
it's not simply about the Equality of
the sexes it's not about denigrating men
and I want to go down that route but
it's about treating women as victims
instead of arguing for women's freedom
today feminism argues for women's
protection and that's a completely
different thing being protected and safe
is completely different from being free
which is inherently involves risk and
excitement and challenges so if we
really want women to be equal to men
which
I think we should one then you have to
start arguing for the different f-word
freedom rather than feminism because it
just isn't serving so you know you could
dress up how you like you can call it
equality feminism you can call it
professional feminism blah blah blah it
still is the same thing that at its
heart it's about protecting women rather
than making them free so do you think
there's a way that you can recognize
inequality without that then putting
onus on those that are unequal so sort
of naming inequality between men and
women could that be that's sort of
taking agency over that inequality
rather than it being like we're victims
of it oh yeah absolutely I mean cuts
calling stuff out as it happens mean for
example in this country one of the main
ways in which women are still treated
differently to men is through abortion
law which stipulates that our bodies men
don't men don't have any rules and
regulations into what kind of health
care they can get or what point they get
stopped from having health care we do
you know once we've become 24 weeks
pregnant in this country then our bodies
are no longer our own we're not able to
do anything about the fact that we might
not want that pregnancy anymore and
that's you know people get to play damn
it's actually a really important thing
to say hang on a minute women are not
equal because they are their bodies are
owned by the state under the current law
call that out that is an inequality it's
there's a huge amount of sexist law
surrounding contraception and the
regulation of that which treats women is
not being able to make up their own
decisions but what you do is you find
the root of what's actually going on
there and what's actually going on there
as a disbelief and women's agency it's
not just the patriarchy this kind of
free-floating
Specter that no one can actually pin
down it's a system of you know it's
capitalism it's the world in which we
live it's the laws in which we've
created you know outline what actually
is going on and tackle that don't engage
in this kind of free-floating
I don't want to use the word circle-jerk
but people have used it of kind of you
know self-congratulation about
victimhood I think we need to get a bit
more proactive if this is a sort of
reason
in feminism like do you see this in sort
of 1960s or 70s is this a problem with
feminism today or just inherently within
feminism well so in the book what women
want I'm I focus in on contemporary
feminism and its issues but actually if
you if you look back at the kind of the
movements of the 60s and 70s while much
of it was very good and very forthright
in arguing for sexual liberation access
to contraception you know arguing for
women's rights in an equality within the
law what also happened was there was a
move towards that kind of cliched phrase
now the personal is political and the
idea that you know some people even
argue that feminism is the original
identity politics in which it said that
everything about a woman's experience in
life is colored by the fact that she is
a woman and so that's you know that's
come to its logical end point today in
which you have you know speaking as a
woman that kind of approach to politics
which is really narrowing and really can
places constraints on women's ability to
engage so actually what we're seeing
today has been there in the kind of
theory of the anti-porn feminists and
Dworkin MacKinnon in the sort of kind of
books like Our Bodies Ourselves which
were part of the family's movement which
said you know women have to really be
obsessed with them selves and argue the
fact that their bodies their personhood
their identity is the political thing so
we're seeing a combination of that today
but it's been coming for a very long
time and so the title of your book what
women want is that ironic because that
still seems that you're talking from a
very like woman's perspective as if
women know best about these issues and
it's just an issue about women well I
mean there are certain things in which
women will have more a better answer to
certain questions so for example in this
country still is the fact that women
though there's no you know official
regulation around it women are still the
ones who are the primary caregivers we
wipe the snotty noses we take the time
off work when kids get sick you know
that's it's a social norm it's not
necessarily a you know we're not tied to
the kitchen sink but we haven't exactly
managed to escape it either and so
talking women talking about that
experiences
pretty good thing but I also think men
can have that conversation as well
childcare should not be an issue just
for women it should be an issue for
society as a whole but the reason why I
called it what women want it was
actually rather than it just being a nod
to the Mel Gibson film it was about
saying that I don't attention to the
fact that feminism today often talks
about how women feel and what women's
emotions are and you know professing
from on high about what women need you
know this law to protect them that man
to shut up all that kind of thing and I
sort of realized no one is asking women
what they want I mean you know does your
average working class women living in
inner London
want the same things politically from
treasom a emily Thorne Bri you know a
CEO who's a female know and so we need
to look at what it is that actually
women want have those questions have
those open questions because actually
sometimes the answers might be not what
today's contemporary feminists like so
some women like catcalling and like
being whistled out some women want to be
stay-at-home mothers and be the only
ones who cook the dinners some you know
there's a variety of an opinion here we
have to actually get together and say
what is it that women want to need
defined by women rather than being
defined by a very small section of
middle-class journalists and you know
politicians with a policy to grind so do
you think feminism has been elitist for
sure I've call it in the book I call it
middle-class Girls Club and that wasn't
me just being nasty it's actually it's
what it has become I mean if you look at
for example the kind of contemporary
feminists who are active in the media
and in politics I mean there's a huge
amount of feminism is always on the
front pages of newspapers
it's we're saturated and it we're always
talking about it that you know if a
politician wants to get a little bit of
kudos all they have to do is your start
up a question about quotas so that it's
there and yet it's you know have the
lives of average women like myself been
changed not necessary
we've got more women in Parliament
thanks to you know Blair's injection of
the Blair's babes and the women's
equality commission calling for more
quotas has anything happened in relation
to abortion rights better provision for
child care no and so it's about saying
you know drawing attention to the fact
that a certain section of women middle
class women have done pretty well women
in their 20s and 30s actually of a
certain section Society out earning men
you know that's they're benefiting from
this kind of politics is your average
working class women benefiting from this
and the answer is a resounding no so yes
it is an elitist project and having a
good time trying to tear it down
so then what where do we go from here so
I was like how do we tear it down is it
through making politics more
representative or do we need a movement
which isn't elitist
yeah which which I don't want to see a
you know someone once suggested to me
well we'll have you know quotas for
different sections of societies women
put on a board you know so we'll have
your mother from a top mistake come on
to assistance in this MV along with the
black academic female and you know it's
not simply a question of representation
it's about a different approach to
politics which puts liberation and
freedom first and as you can see with
any other discussion going on whether it
be Bragg's here or any kind of issue of
British politics a belief in people's
ability to enact change and freedom of
speech and individual autonomy and
agency is at an all-time low
so it has to be part of a wider
discussion about how do we value freedom
how do we value choice there are
practical things that we could do
tomorrow we could scrap the 1967 Act and
the offenses against the People Act and
just take abortion out of criminal law
done we could do that tomorrow and it
would change women's lives radically we
could make childcare a provision in the
same way as the NHS and so you just
eliminate that kind of gender imbalance
that happens and still happens in many
homes there are practical things that
you can do but I think the problem is
not necessarily at the moment simply one
of policy it's about a kind of having a
state
change in the way that we look at
politics doing away with the identity
politics of family ISM and not to keep
pushing the book asking what do women
want what is it actually that we need
and want to be free in 2019 and 2020
because I don't think that the current
badge of feminism is doing that a
service and how do we create a system in
which if we're asking what women want
that is then fed into how the country is
ruled well I mean that's that's again
it's not you know having a female prime
minister would that do it it hasn't you
know having a having a board of females
on a company like Facebook would that
make it a better place no there's a kind
of inherent strange obsession with the
idea of women and femininity that simply
having a woman there makes the world a
better place which is actually kind of
sexist view of us having this kind of
like gentle touch and and having
different qualities to men so it's not
simply about just changing the face of
politics it's actually kind of a far
more complex about saying you know I
think that actually there needs to be a
lot more solidarity between men and
women certainly working-class men and
women about because they have much more
similar interests if two people living
in this state that I grew up on will
have you know a man and a woman will
have almost everything in common in
comparison with you know a woman living
there and a woman living in an Islington
house Terral house we're not going to
have a huge amount in common really are
we other than the fact that we both have
vaginas you know what does that matter
to my lived experience so it's about
growing solidarity between people in in
and expanding the question of freedom
outside of the kind of gender sphere
outside of their identity politics fear
and saying okay so you want to be
treated equally equally in the workplace
and you want better pay right for the
pay gap example all right
let's argue for that for you for that
and let's argue for the male clean over
there who's getting paid pennies to do
his work let's come together and you
know without sounding sort of like a
fairy tale make society a better place
rather than just sort of at the
obsession with the gender wars at the
moment is doing no one any good and
moving on - you've spoken up a brexit
that was a situation which people were
asked what they wanted and we're seeing
that now but you've talked about about
how it's a sham why why do you think
that well as the form of silicone wanna
whisper this I think as I think probably
the only breaks it broke during the
first of all I think that it's a it's a
terrible and wonderful example of the
problem with politics today you having a
clear mandate from a mass vote biggest
mandate in British political history and
do this and politicians absolutely will
not do it and will do anything but do it
and and it's if you know I for years
have been banging on about elitism about
the differentiation between us and them
about you know class prejudice in
society and here you have it writ large
in the reaction to brags it you have a
mass votes that is denied by an ally and
so you know not exactly half and half
but part of me is saying this is the
most terrible thing ever to happen I
wish it hadn't happened and half of me
is saying okay it's out there now the
lines are drawn it's very clear we're in
a better place potentially to build
something different because they can't
hide anymore
it is explicit that we are living under
a government and under the rule ruling
class that's hostile to democracy what
an exciting thing to try and change so
you think this could be remembered as a
time being broken down to show how we
rules to then build it up again I think
that it's that there's a potential and
for what I would hope would be a kind of
left wing populism to galvanize on the
ability of you know the fact that you've
had a mass sentiment for a desire for
change within a populist I mean people
forget that British politics is by and
large kind of like it's it's relatively
hostile to change I mean certainly in
the last 3040 years we've had little to
no change and we used to worry about
questions of apathy and people not being
engaged suddenly you have a mass
movement society that says we want
changed not only do we want change but
we want it even if it's good
hurt us even if there's going to be
risks even if there's going to be
economic upheaval you know god what an
opportunity to really implement
something different and trillion a rip
up the rulebook and start again so
rather than being beaten down by the
torrent of rubbish that you get of anti
brexit sentiment anti working-class
sentiment
you know prejudice that's going on
attacked a browser voters hope kind of
want to say to those of us who believe
in democracy ROFL even remain at this
point now you know as I'm stealing from
Claire Fox now which you stole it from
Michelle Obama I kind of when they go
low we go high I think looking at the
fact that there's such an opportunity
now ignore all the crap and let's just
push forward and not waste this
opportunity and you think the Labour
Party's in a good position to do this I
have so much contempt for the Labor
Party it boils up inside me like like
vomit and because Jeremy Corbyn could
have been someone who because he was a
very strong Euroskeptic could have
galvanized that opportunity and to push
for a you know what from my point of
view would have been a really kind of a
clear statement of democracy and you
know leaving the European Union and
pushing for different step changes in
relation to the house of law or to the
monarchy and in the country and he
squandered it and not only has he
squandered it he is being played by a
party that is so hostile to democracy is
unbelievable you know whether it be Lord
Adonis saying that if you're a label II
voted don't don't vote for us because we
don't care about your vote to Kirsten
took her muna who's now left or David
Lammy and calling brexit voters racist I
mean this used to be a party that
claimed to be on the side of the working
class it is now a party that it's
explicitly got the interest of the
establishment at heart and is set
against the working class so I hope
labor goes to hell very quickly and very
soon because I'm so awfully ashamed for
that party for ever being able to claim
that it was on the side of of the masses
and so here would you like to see as
leader of country
you know I the brexit vote was the first
time that I ever positively voted I
always used to spoil my ballot and and I
just voted in European elections which
was the second time I've ever positively
voted for the brexit party and I Teresa
my going I don't care who's going to be
the conservative Prime Minister I mean
pick me someone who you would trust out
of labour or conservative to deliver
break sit properly now and I don't mean
putting forward the deal I don't mean
you know doing some kind of
Frankenstein's monster brexit but to
actually implement a No Deal breaks it
to get out of the European Union and
then to take the country into a
different kind of more progressive area
of populism you know galvanizing
populism rather than being scared of it
there's none of them who can do it and
I've always had a sort of it's not a
cynicism but it's a kind of truthful
understanding of the fact that the
political establishment
you know labor and conservatives you
can't you can fit a cigarette paper
between them on many things because it's
we've become now just dominated by the
kind of boring
managerial centrism having said that I
think that you know the fact that breaks
it has happened shows that actually
people can do things that are a bit
radical and a bit dangerous and a bit
you know challenging the status quo I'm
hoping that with the you know local
election showing a surge of independence
and with the you know the new success of
the brexit party though not not
necessarily that party that different
elements are going to start coming into
politics we might see some new faces we
might see some new ideas that's the
exciting prospect feminists have a lot
of people that get a lot of time in our
pop culture today I wonder if you have
alternative people who you look up to
who could be alternative role models for
people
well there's one from history and
there's one from now so the one from
history is Sylvia Pankhurst who never
really gets mentioned in discussions
around the suffragettes because she was
the scruffier sister she did terrible
things like once the East End and talked
to the working-class and that wasn't you
know the other Pinecrest didn't like
that and she was auntie the war but she
put forward a
really strong point if incredibly
radical point of view at that time which
was saying that we must demand freedom
with no ifs in the butt so it's not just
suffrage for women but it's suffrage for
all people of a dull age she was
universal suffrage and she was arguing
not just for women to get the vote and
then voting for some kind of you know
status quo politician but to drastically
change the world as it was she was a you
know she was arrested most she was
attacked most and yet she stayed strong
in a time in which women were really
denigrated so any time it gets hairy for
me I always think of Sylvia I think if
she was able to put forward such radical
points of view under the kind of
constraints that she had then I can with
a bit of viewer abuse from Twitter or
something like that I think that we
should be celebrating Sylvia more than
any other suffragette but the one in
recent history has to be Claire Fox
who's the director of the academy of
ideas and it's not that she is talks
about feminism all the time but I think
as a woman who explains her point of
view so clearly and so forcefully and
without restraint it's a kind of I want
to see us rather than celebrating you
know Beyonce or Michelle Obama or even
though those women are great and
interesting in their own right
celebrating the idea that women should
be you know a little bit out there a
little bit forceful and taking up space
and a genuine sense and I think that
Claire Fox has been someone who's had
more attacks and abuse than most but is
one hell of a woman
so and look her up look up the academy
of ideas for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you